social rights
of the women in Islam.
I have broadly divided
the social rights of women in Islam
into four subcategories.
The rights of the daughter in Islam,
the rights of the wife in Islam, the
rights of the mother in Islam, and the
rights of the sister in Islam.
First, we'll discuss
the rights of the daughter in Islam.
The Quran
prohibits the killing of any female
child or female infant.
The Quran says in Surat Takwir, chapter
number 81,
verse number 8 and 9, that the when the
female child is buried alive,
and when she's asked,
"For what crime was she killed?"
Quran
prohibits the killing of female children
and female infants. The Quran does not
only prohibit the killing of female
infants, it prohibits the killing OF ALL
INFANTS, ALL CHILDREN, whether male or
female.
Quran says
in Surat An'am, chapter number 6, verse
number 151, that
"Kill not your children
for want of sustenance.
For it is Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala who
will give sustenance to you and your
children."
Allah repeats the message in Surat Isra,
chapter number 17, verse number 31,
"Kill not your children for want of
sustenance. For it is Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala who will give sustenance to your
children and you. For killing of
children is a major sin."
There was a program
that came on BBC.
The name of the program, Assignment,
and the title was Let Her Die.
There was a British reporter by the name
of Emily Buchanan,
who comes
from UK
and does a survey of India
and she says that every day more than
3,000 fetuses are being aborted in India
after they identified that they are
females. If you multiply this figure by
365, the number of days in a year, you
get a total of more than a million
fetuses are being aborted in India alone
after they identified that they are
females.
And according to the Tamil Nadu
government hospital report, it says out
of 10 female children born alive in the
Tamil Nadu government hospital, four are
put to death.
And there are big billboards and
hoardings
in states such as Rajasthan and Tamil
Nadu saying, "Spend 500 rupees and save
500,000 rupees."
Indicating,
"Spend 500 rupees
and do the ultrasonography.
Identify that the child you're carrying
is a female and abort her and save
the couple of lakhs in upbringing her
and the balance few lakhs in dowry."
"Spend 500 rupees and save 500,000
rupees." Very good bargain.
Because of this evil practice
of female infanticide
and female feticide,
you find the sex ratio in India, it is
imbalanced.
According to the census of 1901,
for every thousand males in India,
there were
and 72 females
in 1901 census.
As science and technology is advancing,
you can identify easily whether the
child is a male or a female. So, as
science and technology is advancing,
the women
are being subjugated.
According to the census
of 1981,
in India, for every thousand males,
there were 934 females.
According to the census of 1991, for
every thousand males,
there were 927 females. You know,
science technology advancing,
women are being subjugated.
As I told you, the Western talk of
women's liberalization is nothing but a
disguised form of exploitation of body,
deprivation of honor, and degradation of
a soul.
If this evil practice of female
infanticide and female fetacide stops,
even in India,
in the next few decades, the male and
the female ratio, inshallah, would
become equal.
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala, our creator,
almighty God, does not only prohibit the
killing of female children, it even
rebukes the thought of a person becoming
sad at the news of a female child.
Quran says in Surah An-Nahl, chapter
number 16, verse number 58 and 59, that
when news is brought to one of them
of the birth of a female child,
his face darkens,
and he's filled with inward grief.
And he starts thinking
that should he let her live in contempt,
or should he bury her alive? Ah, what an
evil thought.
The Quran rebukes the thought of a
person becoming sad at the news of a
birth of a female child. Leave aside
killing, even becoming sad at the news
of a birth of a female child. Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala does not like it.
He rebukes it.
Our beloved prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alayhi wasallam he said,
it's mentioned sahih hadith, volume
number four, the beloved prophet said
that anyone who upbring two daughters
with love and affection till they grow
up, they'll be as close to me as these
two fingers on the day of judgement. And
he kept both his two fingers together.
There's another sahih hadith in which
the prophet said that anyone who upbring
two daughters with love and affection
till they grow, they shall enter jannah.
Our beloved prophet Muhammad sallallahu
alayhi wasallam, he did not only talk
about equality,
he actually practiced it.
Once there was a man
who kissed his son
and placed him on one of his laps,
but did not do the same for his
daughter. The prophet objected and said
that the man was unjust. He should have
even kissed his daughter and placed her
on the other lap.
Now we'll discuss
the rights of the wife in Islam.
Most of the other religions besides
Islam,
they consider the woman as an instrument
of the devil.
But the Quran refers to the woman as a
muhsanah.
Muhsanah in Arabic means a fortress
against the devil.
Because a pious woman who's on the
straight path,
she prevents the husband from deviating
and going on the wrong track and keeps
him on the sirat al-mustaqim.
Therefore she's called as muhsanah, a
fortress against the devil.
The Quran
in Surah Nisa, chapter number four,
verse number 21, refers
to marriage, to nikah, as a sacred
covenant. It's a sacred covenant,
a secret contract
between the husband and wife.
The Quran says in Surah Rum, chapter
number 30, verse number 21,
that
we have created for you mates from
amongst yourselves, so that you may live
with them in tranquility, and he has put
love and mercy between your hearts.
The beloved prophet Muhammad S.A.W.
he said,
it's mentioned in Sahih Bukhari,
volume number seven, in the book of
Nikah, chapter number three, hadith
number 5,066,
the beloved prophet said, "Oh young
people,
whoever has the means to get married
should get married."
The beloved prophet also said, "There is
no monasticism in Islam."
And the prophet said, "Anyone
who marries, he completes half his
deen."
Once during question answer time,
there was a person who asked me, "Then
does it mean that if I marry twice, will
I complete my full deen?"
What did the prophet mean when he said
that marriage completes half your deen?
Marriage
prevents you from promiscuity, from
fornication, from homosexuality.
Only if you marry, do you have an
opportunity to be a husband or a wife.
opportunity to be a father or a mother,
which are very important duties in
Islam. So, irrespective whether you
marry once or twice, you only complete
half your deen.
In Islam, for a marriage to solemnize,
taking the permission of both would-be
husband and wife, the man and the woman,
is equally important.
The Quran says in Surah Nisa, chapter
number four, verse number 19, do not
inherit the women against their wishes.
There's a Hadith which is mentioned in
Sahih Bukhari, volume number seven,
book of Nikah,
chapter number 43, Hadith number 5138.
A lady by the name of Khansa bint Khidam
al-Ansariyah,
she approached the prophet and said that
my father has married me to a person
against my wishes. The prophet, he
nullified the marriage.
There's another Sahih Hadith
which is mentioned in Ahmad ibn Hanbal,
Hadith number 2469,
where a lady approaches the prophet and
says that my parents have forced me to
marry a man against my wishes.
And the prophet said, she has the option
of either continuing the marriage
or nullifying the marriage.
There's a similar Hadith
mentioned in Ibn Majah, Hadith number
1875.
It's the same Hadith.
A woman approaches the prophet and tells
her that my parents have forced me to
marry against my wishes. And the prophet
says, you can either continue the
marriage or you can nullify the
marriage. And the woman says, I
continued the marriage, but I wanted the
woman to know
that the parents cannot force their
daughters to marry someone who they
don't like.
The Quran says in Surah Baqarah,
chapter number two,
verse number 228,
that the women have rights
similar to those against them on terms
equitable,
but the men have a degree of advantage.
Based on this verse of the Quran, men
and women are equal except in
leadership.
The Quran clearly says
that
the women have rights
those similar to them on terms
equitable,
but the men have a degree of advantage.
Now, many of the Muslims, they
misunderstand this ending phrase that
the men have a degree of advantage and
they think that men are superior.
And they quote the verse of the Quran,
"Ar-rijalu qawwamuna ala an-nisa." That
the men are superior to the women. So,
Allah has said, "The men have degree of
advantage, the men are superior."
What they're quoting is the verse of the
Quran which was recited by a wonderful
Qari
from Surah An-Nisa, chapter number four,
verse number 34, which says, "Ar-rijalu
qawwamuna ala an-nisa."
That the men are the qawwam of the
women.
What is the meaning of the Arabic word
qawwam?
Qawwam comes from the root word aqama,
which means to stand up for.
How we have aqama before salah, we stand
up for salah.
So, this
Arabic word qawwam means the men have
one degree of additional responsibility
and one degree additional service
towards the women, not one degree of
superiority to boss over the women.
And if you read
the tafsir of Tabari,
he said Arabic word qawwam means one
degree of additional responsibility.
Because if you read the verse ahead, the
verse says that Allah has given men more
strength than the women. So, because of
that advantage,
it is the duty of the men that they
should take care of the women, they
should not boss over them.
Furthermore, Quran says in Surah
An-Nisa, chapter number four, verse
number 19,
that
treat your wives
with equity and kindness, even if you
dislike her. Means, even if you don't
like your wife, yet treat her with love
and compassion.
And treat her kindly,
even if you dislike her. Even if you
dislike her, treat her with kindness and
compassion.
And in Islam
we do not consider
calling the woman as housewives.
Housewives. You know, housewife if you
analyze means
she's married to the house. In Islam, we
don't consider our women they're married
to the house to be called housewives.
You know, in English we have what is
your profession? Housewife.
We in Islam prefer calling the woman as
homemakers. Because they make the home.
They build the home.
So, inshallah I believe that
the ladies from now onwards when they
have to fill any form
instead of writing the profession if
they are not write housewife, that's
English terminology. They're marrying
you to your house.
Prefer mentioning homemaker. Because the
woman builds the home. They make the
home.
And in Islam a woman is not married to a
master to be treated like a slave.
She's married to an equal and the role
is that of partnership.
And Quran gives a very good phrase
in Surah Baqarah, chapter number two,
verse 2:187 where Almighty God says,
"Hunna libasun lakum wa antum libasun
lahunna." That they are your garments
and you are their garments. That means
your wives are your garments.
And you are the garments of your wives.
What is the role of garment?
The role of the garments
is
to beautify,
to conceal,
to protect.
The husband and wife
they conceal each other's faults.
They beautify each other. They help each
other.
It is a role of hand in glove.
Let's discuss
the rights of the mother in Islam.
Allah says in the Quran
in Surat Isra, chapter number 17, verse
number 23 and 24.
We have ordained for the human beings
that they worship none but Allah.
And they be kind to the parents.
And if one of them or both of them reach
old age, don't say a word of contempt.
Don't say "Ugh" to them.
But address them
with honor.
And lower to them
your wing of humility.
And pray to Almighty God
that have mercy on them and bless them
as they cherish me in childhood.
Almighty God says that after worshiping
Almighty God, the next point is
that you have to be good to the parents.
And if one of them or both of them reach
old age, don't say "Ugh" to them.
And address them with honor.
And lower to them your wing of humility.
And pray to Almighty God
that have mercy on them. And cherish
them. Bless them as they cherish me in
childhood.
The Quran says
in Surat An'am, chapter number six,
verse number 151. And Surat Ankabut,
chapter number 29, verse number eight.
Wabil walidaini ihsana.
That we have enjoined on the human
beings to be kind to the parents.
The Quran repeats the same message in
Surat Luqman, chapter number 31, verse
number 14. And Surat Al-Ahqaf, chapter
number 46, verse number 15. That we have
enjoined on the human beings to be good
to the parents. And the verse continues,
especially to the mothers.
The Quran says in Surat An-Nisa, chapter
number four, verse number one. Respect
the womb that bore you.
And our beloved Prophet Muhammad
is mentioned in several Hadith including
the Hadith of Sunan Nisai
the book of Jihad chapter number six
Hadith number 3106. The beloved prophet
said, "Paradise lies beneath the feet of
your mother."
That does not mean that if my mother is
walking on the street and if she walks
on
filth and dirt, that thing becomes
paradise. What the prophet meant was
when he said, "Paradise lies beneath the
feet of your mother." means if you love
your mother, if you respect your mother,
if you're obedient to your mother, if
you're kind to your mother, inshallah,
you shall enter paradise.
There's a Hadith in Sahih Bukhari in
volume number eight
in the book of Adab, the book of good
manners, chapter number two
Hadith number
two
in the new edition of Bukhari, it's
Hadith number 5971.
Where a man approaches the prophet and
asks him
that who in this world deserves the
maximum love and compassion?
The beloved prophet said
"It's your mother."
The man asked, "After that, who?"
The prophet said, "Your mother."
The man asked, "After that, who?" The
prophet said, "Your mother." THE MAN
ASKED, "AFTER THAT, WHO?" THEN THE
PROPHET SAID, "Your father."
That means 75%
of the love and compassion goes to your
mother.
25% goes to your father.
3/4 of the love and compassion goes to
the mother and 25% of the love and
compassion
goes to the father.
In short
the mother gets the gold medal.
She gets the silver medal as well as the
bronze medal. The father has to be
satisfied with the mere consolation
prize.
These are the teachings of Islam. I've
got no option over it.
Let's discuss
the rights of the sister in Islam.
The Quran says in Surah Tawbah, chapter
number nine, verse number 71,
that
the believing men and women, they are
supporters unto one another. That means
they socially support each other. They
are like brothers and sisters unless
otherwise.
And our beloved prophet Muhammad
Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam, he referred
to the woman as shaqqaq.
One of the meaning of the Arabic word
shaqqaq
means a sister.
The other meaning is one half.
And we know the world population is
divided approximately into equal halves
of male and female.
So, one half is male, one half is
female. And the prophet referred to the
woman as a sister.
Just because
the social rights
in Islam
are played dominant, what would you say?
That are the
women's rights in Islam?
Are they protected or are they
subjugated?
Let's discuss
the educational rights of the women in
Islam.
The first guidance
revealed by Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala, by
Almighty God, to the whole of humankind
in this last and final revelation, the
glorious Quran, it was not to offer
salah.
It was not to give charity.
It was not to fast.
But it was iqra.
It was to read, to proclaim,
to repeat.
And the first five verses
revealed of the glorious Quran
was
from Surah Iqra, chapter number 96,
verse number one to five. It says, "Iqra
bismi rabbika alladhi khalaq. Khalaqa
al-insana min alaq. Iqra wa rabbuka
Read, recite, proclaim in the name of
the Lord who created. Who created
the men from something which clings, a
leech-like substance.
Read in the name of the Lord who's most
bountiful.
Who taught men the use of the pen. Who
taught men that which he did not know.
The first guidance given by Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala in the Quran, it was
to read.
And it was to both male and female.
Our beloved Prophet Muhammad Sallallahu
Alaihi Wasallam said,
it's mentioned in Sahih Hadith of Ibn
Majah,
Hadith number 224,
the beloved Prophet said,
it is obligatory on every Muslim, man or
woman, to acquire knowledge.
The Prophet specially told the parents
to educate the children, especially the
daughters.
It is the duty of the husband
to give education to their
wife,
especially religious education.
And if they don't, she has the right to
go to the court, to the judge,
and demand for it. If he cannot teach it
himself,
he'll have to send her and see to it
that he educates her.
There is a chapter in Sahih Bukhari.
In one Hadith, the women
they approach the Prophet
and they tell him that you're always
surrounded by men. Why don't you give us
a special time? And the Prophet agreed.
And he used to specially dedicate time
to educate only the women. He also sent
Sahabas to specially educate the women.
And if you read the history of Islam,
1,400 years ago,
in the days of ignorance in Yomal
Jahiliya at that time we have examples
of many women, several women who were
scholars.
The best example I can think
is
Aisha bint Abi Bakr.
May Allah be pleased with her, the wife
of the prophet.
And one of her very famous student
by the name of Urwah
may Allah be pleased with her, she says
that I have not come across
a scholar greater than Aisha
may Allah be pleased with her
in
learning of the Quran
in obligatory duties
in lawful and unlawful things
in literature and poetry
in Arabic history and genealogy.
And when we read
the seal of Hazrat Aisha may Allah be
pleased with her
we find out that she lived
many years after death of the prophet
and she guided many of the Sahabas.
And she even guided all the four Khalifa
Rashidin.
Many a time
when foreign delegations
came to the prophet and when they
discussed medicine etc.
Hazrat Aisha may Allah be pleased with
her, her memory was very good. She used
to memorize them.
She was also an expert in mathematics.
And after the demise of the prophet many
of the Sahabas came to her
especially when dealing with Mirath,
when dealing with inheritance
because she was expert in mathematics.
History tells us that she has taught
several scholars.
She has taught no less than 88 different
scholars. So in short she was a scholar
of the scholars.
And only on her authority alone, there
are no less than 2,210
hadith reported only on the authority of
Aisha, may Allah be pleased with her.
We have the example of Umm Salamah,
may Allah be pleased with her,
who was the wife of the prophet.
And
according
to Imam an-Nawawi,
she was
the most intellectual woman amongst the
learned women.
And according to Ibn Hajar,
he calls her
as an authority.
We have the example of Safiyyah, may
Allah be pleased with her, who was the
wife of the prophet.
And Imam an-Nawawi calls her as an
intellectual woman.
We have the example of Fatimah bint
Qays,
who was one of the
sahabiyyah
of Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alayhi
wasallam, but she was so learned and the
immense knowledge she had that once
there was a discussion on issue of fiqh,
and she had a point of view,
and Hazrat Aisha, may Allah be pleased
with her, and Hazrat Uthman, may Allah
be pleased with him, they objected, but
they could not prove her wrong.
She was so knowledgeable.
We have the example of
Umm Sulaym, may Allah be pleased with
her,
who was the mother of Hazrat Anas, may
Allah be pleased with him, who was a
famous sahabah.
And according to Ibn Hajar,
he says
that
she was a very intelligent woman, and
Imam an-Nawawi calls her as authority.
We have the example of Umm Darda,
who was the wife of Abu Darda.
And Imam Bukhari,
in his
Sahih Bukhari, he calls her as an
authority on the science of hadith.
We have the example of Sayyidah Nafisah.
Sayyidah Nafisah,
she was a scholar
and she taught
many students.
One amongst her students was Imam Shafi.
May Allah have mercy on him.
We also have the example of Aisha bint e
Sa'd
ibn Abi Waqqas.
She too was a scholar and amongst her
students, one of the students was Imam
Malik.
May Allah have mercy on him.
Rahimahullah.
Imagine
in the days of ignorance, in Yawm
al-Jahiliyyah, there were several women
who were scholars.
At that time,
people were hardly educated and imagine
we have examples of several women who
were great scholars.
Let's discuss
the legal rights of the women in Islam.
Legally,
men and women are equal.
If for the crime they commit,
they get the same punishment.
For example, if a man kills a woman,
the man is put to death. If a woman
kills a man,
she's put to death. According to the law
of Qisas, mentioned in Surah Baqarah,
chapter number two, verse number 178 and
179.
And furthermore,
if any organ of the body is damaged,
irrespective whether it's the eye, the
ear, the hand, irrespective whether it's
a man or woman, male or female, the
punishment is the same.
And if suppose someone murders
someone and if the family members want
to forgive by taking diya money, it
doesn't make a difference who is
forgiving, whether a family member is a
man or a woman, both of them are equal.
They have the right to forgive.
The punishment
for
the men and women in Islam for the same
crime, it is the same.
Allah says in the Quran in Surah
Ma'idah, chapter number five, verse
number 38.
As to the thief,
be it a man or a woman, chop off his or
her hand as a punishment from Allah
Subhana Wa Ta'ala. If someone robs,
irrespective whether it's a male or a
female, the punishment is the same, it
is the chopping of the hand.
Quran says in Surah Nur, chapter number
24, verse number two.
As for the fornicator,
whether it's a female or a male, whether
it's a woman or a man,
give each 100 lashes as punishment.
That means if someone does fornication,
irrespective whether it's a woman or a
man, the punishment is the same, 100
lashes.
In Islam, legally men and women are
same.
The woman
even have a right
to be a witness.
In most of the religions,
women are not permitted to be a witness.
Even the Jewish community,
just a few decades earlier, at last late
in 1950, they were discussing should
they give the woman the right to be a
witness. Islam gave that right for a
woman to be a witness 1400 years ago.
And
Quran
protects the woman.
Quran says in Surah Nur, chapter number
24, verse number four, that if someone
lays an allegation
against the chastity and modesty of a
woman and does not produce four
witnesses,
give him 80 lashes as punishment. That
means if you lay an allegation
on the modesty or chastity of a woman,
and if you cannot produce four
witnesses, you get 80 lashes.
For a small crime in Islam, you produce
two witnesses. For a big crime, four
witnesses. That means
in today's world,
it is so common
day and night, you have men and women
abusing each other. You know, the men,
they call dirty names to the women. Many
of them call them prostitute.
In Islamic country, in Islamic state of
law,
if a man does such a thing to a woman,
calls her a prostitute, and if he cannot
produce four witnesses,
he gets 80 lashes.
And if he produces four witnesses, and
if any one of them falter, all of them
get 80 lashes.
This is how much Islam protects the
women. I don't know in any law in the
world, whether it be America, whether it
be UK, whether it be Canada, whether it
be India.
If you take an objection, if a woman
goes to the court of law and says that
man abused me,
what can you do?
I don't know of any case in which a
woman took a man for abusing her.
What punishment? In Islamic law, 80
lashes.
If that law is implemented anywhere in
the world, a man will think a million
time before abusing a woman.
This is how Islam protects the women.
And
in the Western world,
when a woman marries a man,
she takes the name of the husband.
In Islam, she has option
to take husband's name or maintain her
maiden name. And in many of the Islamic
countries, the women even after marrying
a man, she maintains her maiden name.
Let's discuss
the political rights of the women in
Islam.
Allah says in the Quran
in Surat Tawbah, chapter number nine,
verse number 71.
The believing men and the believing
women, they are supporters
of one another. Not only socially, but
even politically.
And Allah says in the Quran in Surat
Mumtahanah, chapter number 60,
verse number 12, that "O prophet, when
the women come to thee for an oath of
fealty." That big word is bay'ah.
It is far superior to the modern voting
that we have. In modern voting, we
select the head of state. But here, the
prophet beside the women
agreeing that he is the head of state,
they also agreed that he was the
messenger of Allah. He was the prophet
of Allah. It is far superior than the
modern voting system that we have today.
In Islam, the woman can also take part
in law making.
One of the occasion when Hazrat Umar,
may Allah be pleased with him,
the second caliph of Islam, he was
discussing with the Sahabah's
that should we put an upper limit
for the mehr. The women they are
demanding too much money for marriage,
so should we put an upper limit? So
there was a woman
who objected from the back seat of the
mosque.
Even the woman's name is not mentioned.
That means it was an ordinary woman.
It wasn't a woman who was a great
scholar. It was an ordinary woman who
objected from the back seat of the
mosque and said that when Allah Subhana
Wa Ta'ala has not put an upper limit,
for what the Quran says in Surat
An-Nisa, chapter four, verse number 20,
you can even give a mountain of gold. So
when Allah, our creator, has not put an
upper limit, who is Umar,
may Allah be pleased with him, to put an
upper limit? And the caliph of Islam,
Hazrat Umar, may Allah be pleased with
him, he said, "Umar is wrong and the
woman is right." That means she took an
objection to the breach of constitution.
And this hadith is
classified as a sahih hadith.
Women
There are chapters in Bukhari
who even took part in the battlefield.
They went
and gave water to the soldiers.
They gave first aid to the soldiers.
To the men.
And there is an incident mentioned in
Sahih Bukhari
where a lady
by the name of Nafisa
during Battle of Uhud
she was amongst the other Sahabas
who were around the prophet
and they protected the prophet. And
while doing that, she received wounds
and the prophet praised her for her
bravery.
This was in short
regarding the rights of the women in
Islam.
But as I mentioned earlier to you
in Islam
men and women are equal.
Equality does not mean identicality.
Depending upon the makeup depending upon
the background men and women they are
different.
Physiologically psychologically
biologically, physically and depending
upon the makeup, Almighty God, our
creator has set roles for them.
And
there is a verse in the Quran
from Surah Nisa, chapter number four,
verse number 32.
The ayah
our honored Qari from Saudi Arabia, Dr.
Uthman, recited.
The third last ayah he recited, Surah
Nisa, chapter 4:32.
It says
that do Do covet things.
Don't
say this is right or this is wrong. You
may never know. Allah knows what is best
for you.
What you may think is best for you may
not be good for you.
What you think is bad for you may be
good for you. If you read the news in
the Quran,
why was this verse revealed? This verse
was revealed because the wives of the
prophet they objected to the prophet and
said that why can't we too go for jihad?
We want our rights.
What about inheritance?
Why aren't we equal? This verse was
revealed.
Because Allah knows the logic, you don't
know.
And I gave you the logic of inheritance.
Imagine the women want to go for jihad,
they want to fight.
Our beloved prophet Muhammad S.A.W.
said,
when Aisha may Allah be pleased with her
asked,
that can you go for jihad? It's
mentioned in Sahih Bukhari. The prophet
said, the best jihad for the women, it
is a perfect hajj.
Allah knows what is good for them.
And
those people who object to Islam and the
Quran, they too know,
but they don't want to admit.
This western world, this western media,
which are pointing fingers to Islam,
I'm asking this media,
the western world, they too, if they say
that Islam subjugates the women, they
are bigger subjugators. I ask a simple
question.
That when you have sports,
why do you have men and women taking
part separately?
In Olympics,
for the 100 m dash,
why don't the men and women run
together?
Why? Why separate for men and separate
for women? Why?
When you have swimming, freestyle
swimming, why men and women are
separate? Why? They should have
together.
You know, when you have lawn tennis
and badminton, men's badminton, women's
badminton. Why?
You know, you have mixed double. Mixed
double means one man, one woman.
Means one is superior, one is inferior.
Mixed double.
Why don't you have two men and two women
against each other? You have one man,
one woman in one team, other team one
man, one woman.
Why don't you have two men in one team
and two women in the other team if they
equal?
Because
the Western world knows that physically
men and women are different.
Why don't you go and tell the judges of
Olympics, "WHY ARE YOU SUBJUGATING the
women? Why don't you let the women and
men run together?"
Has any media ever objected to the
Olympics?
To the Wimbledon?
No.
You have boxing matches.
Have men and women together against each
other. Why not?
See, when you appear for your
examination,
standard 10, men and women sit together.
When you appear for graduation, men and
women appear because they know, fine,
where studies are concerned, men and
women are equal.
But where physical thing is concerned,
they're different.
You know, you have beauty contest.
In beauty contest, you have female
separate and male separate. Do you have
together?
Do you have any beauty contest where you
have seen the men and women taking part
together?
Have you seen any?
Why?
Because the beauty of a woman differs
than a beauty of a man.
So, even the Western world knows that.
But they don't want to admit it.
So, many a time
the competition
they are identical.
Sometimes, they aren't identical. So,
depending upon
what field are they competing in, we
decide.
Oh, yeah.
Men, women are separate. Yeah, men, and
are same. But who is better than our
creator? Who knows the human being
better than our creator?
Allah Subhana Wa Ta'ala. And he has
mentioned in the Quran, his last and
final revelation, where the women and
men are identical, where they are
different. Overall, men and women are
equal, but they are not identical. And I
would like to end my talk by giving a
simple example to you.
Suppose, in a class,
two students, A and B,
both get 80 out of 100
in the examination, and both come out
first.
When you examine the answer sheet,
the 10 questions,
each carrying 10 marks.
When you examine the answer sheet, you
come to know that student A
got nine out of 10 in answer number one.
Student B gets seven out of 10 in answer
number one. So, in answer number one,
student A has a degree of advantage over
student B.
In answer number two, B gets nine out of
10, and student A gets seven out of 10.
So, in answer number two,
student B has a degree of advantage over
A. In all the remaining eight answers,
from question number three to question
number 10, both student A and B, they
get eight out of 10. Both are equal.
If you total,
the aggregate is 80 out of 100, both are
equal. But, in answer number one,
student A has a degree of advantage.
Answer number two, student B has a
degree of advantage. All the other
answers, both are equal.
So, similarly in Islam, Allah Subhana Wa
Ta'ala knows
where women are equal, they have equal
role.
Where they are identical, wherever they
are identical, they have identical role.
In some aspects, the men have a degree
advantage. In some aspects, the women
have a degree of advantage. For example,
where it comes
for love and compassion towards parents,
as I mentioned the Hadith of Bukhari,
volume number eight,
book of Adab, book of manners, chapter
number two,
Hadith number
5971,
where a man comes and asks the prophet,
"Who deserves the maximum love and
compassion?" The prophet said, "Your
mother, your mother, your mother, and
then the father." So, here the mother
gets three times more
love and compassion from the children as
compared to the father. So, here the
mother has a degree of advantage.
But for example,
if
a robber enters my house, if a thief
enters my house,
I'll not tell my wife and my daughter,
"Go and fight. I believe in women's
rights."
Allah says in the Quran in the Surah
Nisa, chapter number four, verse number
34, "Allah has given more strength to
the men as compared to the women." So,
it's my duty to fight. One degree
additional responsibility supporting
her.
Have ever men objected that why can't I
give birth to a child?
That's the prerogative of the female.
Why don't the men object that why can't
I breastfeed the child?
That's the prerogative of the female.
So, depending upon the biological
makeup, depending upon the physiological
makeup, depending upon psychological
makeup, Almighty God
has given different roles for the men
and women. Sometimes the men have a
degree of advantage, sometimes the women
have a degree of advantage. Overall, men
and women are equal. That's the reason.
If
you analyze
the women's rights in Islam based on
Quran and authentic Hadith, you have no
option but to agree that the women in
Islam, they are protected and they are
not subjugated. Wa al-hamdu lillahi
rabbil
alameen.